motorcycle riders are 28 times more
likely to die in a crash than someone in
a car that's according to the national
highway safety traffic Administration
just this week a rider died in North Las
Vegas in a hit and run these crashes
leading to some call to call for change
rather Joshua piguero spoke to a man who
wants local lawmakers to intervene
Josh talbus is a veteran and a long time
motorcycle rider who decided last year
he's no longer riding on Valley streets
you can be as defensive as you want
you're always looking for a driver to
pull out in front of you but you only
have a split second and sometimes you
just don't have that reaction time and
if somebody's going to pull out in front
of you I mean there's sometimes there's
no avoidance Tapas launched a change.org
petition to call attention to this issue
he has more than 1500 signatures and it
continues to grow Tapas says he wants
harsher penalties for those who crash
into motorcyclists just seeing so many
people especially here in Vegas getting
killed I mean especially car versus
motorcycle it seems like every at least
once a week this week police say a moped
with two passengers was rear-ended in
North Las Vegas at the intersection of
Belmont Street and Dunn Avenue
both weren't wearing helmets and a woman
writer was pronounced dead at the scene
investigators aren't asking for help in
finding the pickup truck that hit them
these motorcycle riders are learning
behaviors that will reduce their chances
of being involved in a crash rather than
eliminated
the College of Southern Nevada has a
beginner's motorcycle course Lori
Sanders is one of the instructors
whether it's a car whether it's a
motorcycle many of the crashes that
happen are a result of somebody's poor
decision poor choice the course is five
hours of online learning and two days of
meeting and writing Sanders says
motorcyclists can protect themselves by
wearing a helmet and cars by just
slowing down how many times on your way
to work are you stopped the roads closed
because somebody else made a poor
decision Sanders adds that drivers need
to be fully aware of their surroundings
in North Las Vegas Joshua progero 8 News
Now